es la declaración más fuerte de la onu
sobre mi animar una resolución que
condena a la junta militar que derrocó
al gobierno del país la asamblea general
de la onu ha anunciado oficialmente
golpes militares pocas veces desde los
años 90 sin embargo uno de los
principales partidarios de la resolución
el embajador de mi hermana ante la onu
pidió una acción aún más contundente es
el primer funcionario de alto rango que
desertó desde el golpe
estamos tan decepcionados de que hayan
sido necesario casi tres meses para
aprobar esta resolución suavizada y
aunque no incluyen muchos puntos
importantes para salvar la vida de la
población de mianmar en llama
la resolución pide el restablecimiento
de la transición democrática del país y
la liberación de los funcionarios
gubernamentales detenidos sobre todo
insta la comunidad internacional a
contener el flujo de armas en el país
el borrador inicial incluye un embargo
de armas completo pero esa referencia
tuvo que eliminarse tras la oposición de
varios países de la asean la medida se
produce mientras la onu advierte sobre
una escalada de violencia
time el tiempo es esencial la
oportunidad de revertir la toma del
poder militar se está reduciendo y la
amenaza regional aumenta el riesgo de
una guerra civil a gran escala es real
of north sails y billboard will
informes denuncian que las fuerzas
gubernamentales incendiaron una aldea
entera en la región de mauá y el
miércoles varios testigos dijeron que
tuvieron que huir cuando los soldados
entraron disparando al lugar
las protestas diarias han sacudido el
país el levantamiento se ha enfrentado
con una brutal represión militar que ha
matado a cientos de civiles